[Music]
the movie is set in a dystopian world
which is still reeling from the
aftermath of a nuclear war due to the
high levels of radiation the atmosphere
has become poisonous and the land has
become unsuitable for agriculture the
water sources have also depleted and
there is a serious lack of other
essentials like food and fuel because of
all this the remaining population of
humans have gone crazy and they
constantly fight against one another for
survival although the world has now
become mostly deserted legend says that
there is a city called green place which
has abundant water greenery and food for
anyone to survive it also has an
extremely uncreative name next we are
shown a city named the citadel which is
a system of caves that lies on a cliff
the citadel has a large community of
survivors who are deformed and look half
dead due to radiation and lack of food
and water the citadel is led by a
monster-like old man immortan joe who
wears a face mask with air pipes to
breathe he is also the only person in
the entire city to have wives in fact he
has five of them god damn the radiation
killed off almost all of the fertile and
beautiful women so having five wives is
a luxury which only the richest can
afford in this world joe trades water
food and milk with fuel and armaments
with other clans he has taken control
over the only water source found in
westland aqua cola as if it's something
he invented and owns not only water he
trades mother's milk too joe has hired a
crew of women so that he can harvest
their breast milk and trade it with
other clans geez i don't remember that i
just remember cars exploding and stuff
his close acquaintances are the gas town
clan which he trades for fuel and the
bullet farm clan which has a large
collection of weapons meanwhile joe
addresses the crowd from a cliff and
mentions that he is their redeemer he is
also the leader of the war boys a bunch
of cancer-inflicted patients who are
willing to die for him joe mentions that
the citadel will rise from the ashes and
become a prosperous clan saying this
much he releases some water but only for
a few seconds after joe shuts off the
water supply the people go crazy and
fight for it joe warns the crowd to not
get too addicted with water so that they
will not resent its absence joe then
sends his lieutenant imperitor furiosa
who has a prosthetic arm to collect fuel
and bullets shortly after she leaves in
a war rig while several war boys
accompany her in smaller vehicles later
on the way furiosa diverts her rig and
starts heading east her war boys are
confused by the sudden change of plans
but since they are loyal to her they
don't ask much elsewhere joe finds out
about furious's change of direction and
immediately heads to his chambers where
he has locked his wives when he reaches
there he is stunned to find that they
are all gone a message on the wall reads
that their children will not be warlords
implying that they will have run away
from him here we get to know that
furiosa has betrayed her master and is
escaping the place with the women in the
next scene we are introduced to the
protagonist max a road warrior who is
searching for a righteous cause nowadays
he is constantly bothered by visions of
the dead who he couldn't protect from
the war as he is gazing around the
deserted place the war boys appear out
of nowhere prompting max to drive off
however he doesn't get far as the war
boys destroy his vehicle and tie him up
then they drag him to the citadel inside
the cave the warboys trim his hair and
beard they also make tattoos on his back
one being written as a universal donor
oh negative as they intend to use him as
a blood bank when they try to brand max
with a burning iron having the shape of
a skull he manages to free himself and
escape he fights several scavengers
along the way but just then he starts
getting visions of the dead this
distracts him momentarily allowing the
war boys to capture him again in the
next scene joe orders his war boys to go
i keep saying that word to go after
furiosa while everyone is preparing for
war an almost dead war boy named nux
takes max along with him as he
desperately needs blood he chains max to
his vehicle and transfuses his blood so
that he gets the constant energy
required for the battle following this
the whole gang drives off and uh is no
one gonna talk about that guitarist with
the flamethrower guitar okay meanwhile
furios's war rig is attacked by another
scavenging tribe buzzards she manages to
defeat them but soon notices the large
horde of soldiers sent by joe scared she
drives into a massive sandstorm in hopes
that she can lose her pursuers the plan
works
partially all of joe's minions stop
except for knox he is hell-bent on
pleasing his master having a lovely day
so he pours fuel into his car and
attempts to ram it with furious's war
rig his plan is to sacrifice his life
and to become a martyr while also
killing furiosa however due to the
sandstorm he loses control of the car
and crashes it nearby after a while max
rises from the sand and notices that he
is chained to knox who is still
unconscious on walking a bit further he
finds furiosa's rig where the five girls
are cleaning themselves up here we get
to know that one of the girls splendid
is nine months pregnant with joe's child
max asks the girls to cut off his chain
that ties him to knox but they fail to
do so just then furiosa notices joe's
men approaching in the distance she
prepares to leave with the girls but max
demands to be freed first with this the
two get into a fight max eventually
overpowers furiosa and even manages to
cut his chain off he then gets into the
war rig and drives away leaving everyone
behind what a prick as the girls think
that they're doomed the rig stops nearby
it turns out that furiosa has installed
a kill switch in the rig which only she
knows how to restart because of this max
reluctantly lets all the girls inside he
also promises to lead them to a place
called green place which is supposedly a
safe haven for girls but still has a
stupid-ass name later furiosa drives the
rig to a canyon ruled by biker bandits
called the rock riders she has already
made a deal with them which states that
they will get to pass the area in
exchange for 3 000 gallons of fuel as
furiosa gets out of the rig to negotiate
the rock riders spot the large horde of
joe's troops arriving this violates the
deal as furiosa mentioned that only a
few people would be passing through not
an entire city the bikers are furious
but before they can take any action
furiosa enters the rig and drives away
however the bikers are not going to let
up so easily on her so they start
following the rig with this an intense
chase ensues but once again the heroes
managed to kill the bad guys one by one
by this time the war boys have also
closed in on the rig as joe tries to
shoot at the reg splendid opens the door
and makes herself a shield for everyone
she is sure that joe will not hurt their
baby surprisingly he holds back as he is
adamant on giving birth to a successor
nux tries to console him that they will
get the girls back but this only angers
joe and he leaves nux behind meanwhile
as splendid tries to climb back inside
the rig she slips and falls joe tries to
save her but only ends up running her
over when he stops he finds splendid's
lifeless body and screams in anguish in
the next scene nux who is disappointed
with joe manages to enter the rig there
he changes sides and promises to help
the girls escape at first they are
skeptical about his motives but when nux
mentions that he doesn't have many days
left to live they take him in as they
drive through the night their rig
suddenly gets stuck in the mud to make
matters worse the bullet farmer gang
starts approaching them it turns out
that joe has sent the gang and returned
for a large amount of water with all
hopes now seeming to be lost nux comes
up with an idea he tells max to tie a
rope around a tree so that the rig can
use it as leverage surprisingly the plan
works and the group gets out of there
before the enemies arrive the following
morning max wakes up in the rig haunted
by the visions of the dead furiosa tells
him to get some rest as she explains to
him about the green place where she was
born and abducted in her childhood since
she wants redemption and joe's wives
want hope for their lives they decided
to run from the citadel after a while
they reach a place in the desert with a
tower where a woman the valkyrie screams
for help although max thinks it's a trap
furiosa steps out of the rig and shouts
her mother's name and her clan's name
seeds soon the valkyrie climbs down the
tower and she is joined by several other
elderly women on bikes they all spend a
moment of joy as they're reuniting after
decades following this furiosa asks
directions to the green place but to her
horror the women reveal that the place
has become desolate and is not suitable
for living anymore they explain that the
muddy swamp they passed through was the
green place but it is now poisonous and
infertile they also reveal that the
remaining mothers of their clan have
died long ago hearing all this a
shattered furiosa falls on her knees and
breaks down in despair later that night
furiosa tells max that the seeds will
help them ride across the salt flats to
find a new home the only problem is that
they have to leave the rig and ride on
bikes for about 160 days to reach there
as expected max despises the idea and
tells furiosa that he won't be joining
them the next morning max gets a
terrible vision of his dead daughter
when he wakes up everyone is already
gone max realizes that he cannot make
the same mistakes again which led to his
daughter's demise so he quickly drives
to the bikers he stops them and asks
them to go back to citadel which has
abundant water and food crops also the
place is unguarded now since joe and the
war boys have been in pursuit of them
furiosa thinks long and hard about it
but after she realizes that max is
correct she agrees soon the group rides
in the rig accompanied by the seeds on
their bikes joe sees the rig going
towards the canyon and realizes that
they are driving back to the citadel
since it's unguarded worried he
immediately tells his men to pursue the
rig after a bit of high speed chasing
the war boys finally catch up with
furyo's rig and a brutal war ensues
several of joe's men are killed but the
good guys also suffer casualties in the
form of the bikers furiosa is also
injured when a war boy jumps onto her
with a dagger with the war getting more
brutal by the minute furiosa and her
group somehow managed to get an upper
hand with the help of knox she manages
to get onto joe's rig the two then start
tussling in the moving vehicle but
furiosa eventually ends the fight when
she attaches joe's mask onto the wheels
taking his face off and killing him
instantly despite the leader being
killed the war boys are still fighting
with all their might just then knox who
is driving a large fuel tanker thinks of
a plan his entire life has been
unappreciated and assaulted so he wants
to perish with a good cause in short he
wants to help the innocent girls escape
from the tyranny of the war boys soon he
violently swerves his vehicle and
crashes against a rock a large explosion
occurs and it finally kills all of the
war boys sadly nux also loses his life
but it was a decision he had made long
ago elsewhere on the way to the citadel
furiosa becomes severely weak and
collapses as the other girls start
panicking max steps in he makes a small
cut underneath furios's lungs to help
her breathe when the plan doesn't work
he gives her a transfusion of his own
blood luckily the procedure works and
furiosa slowly opens her eyes soon the
group arrives at the citadel where max
reveals joe's mouthless corpse to the
people making everyone excited yeah [ __ ]
the war boys the people of the citadel
rip off joe's corpse as they are happy
that the tyrannical rule has finally
come to an end they then start shouting
to let furiosa and joe's wives inside
the cave as they are the real rulers
with the public support against them
joe's war boys reluctantly comply and
make the ladies their rulers as furiosa
and her group overlook the entire crowd
she notices max silently leaving the
place since his promise has now been
fulfilled he will venture to new lands
where other people are in need of help
the movie ends as an unlimited supply of
water is released from the cave sending
everyone into a state of frenzy
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching